so you're looking at your Oscar ballot
you see sound editing you see sound
mixing what's the difference how do you
pick a winner today we have a panel of
sound mixers and editors with us to help
you make a sound decision so I think one
of the fundamental questions is when
people are looking at the categories for
sound mixing sound Eddie help me out a
little bit what's the difference a
simple analogy perhaps is most people
will understand the relationship that
the cinematographer has to the editor
the cinematographer captures all the
various pieces of film and hands those
to the editor and the editor compiles
that into a cohesive whole you don't
shoot in sequence you don't cut in
camera so the sound editor would be the
person who gathers the elements and
presents them to the mixer to organize
as a cinematographer would hand their
shots to the editor to compile into a
completed film we are team it starts
with production from production sound it
goes to sound editorial sound effects
they create the sounds and everything
and then it goes to the recording mixer
well they mix the final product together
I'm a production sound mixer so I work
during the filming I recorded the
dialogue as clean as I can record it
thinking of the sound editor because you
have to try to keep things clean no
overlaps you're really trying to just
keep as consistent a level as you can in
a very uncontested environment and I'm a
production sound mixer as well and for
example if someone is walking at night
as walking and they have keys on and
visually the director wants to see the
key so what we do is that we take the
keys off now the sound editorial later
on they will create the sound the seas
might be special they might have to have
a kind of musical element to them or a
signature or something and they they tie
into a deeper part of the story so the
production keys look right but maybe we
don't want that sound right so you know
we might record these keys on our own or
on a Foley stage or perform them a
certain way or process them to make them
sound more interesting or pitch them to
match the music in a certain case or
something unique if you think with Mark
and air
as sound editors there are also sound
creators you're creating environments
environments that we don't have any idea
maybe what they sound like because
they're in the future there 400 years in
the past then we have to consider the
spoken word the dialogue the music how
the director wants the scene to play
what's the emotion and it's a very
finite dance trying to create an
atmosphere for the viewer to envelop
themselves in and feel part of this
movie ultimately dialogue is king a
movie duck cannot sound great if you
can't understand the dialogue so you
want the audience to believe that what
they're hearing was what was captured as
if everything was happening while it the
film was shot it is so believable that
all we needed was Willie and Steve
because it's so jarring when the sound
doesn't hook up to your sense of what
you're looking at well that's what
people notice people very rarely notice
good sound they really known as bad
sound well let's talk about good sound
versus great sound is there one thing
that makes a nominee distinctive for me
it's storytelling anytime a sound
whether it's dialogue sound effects or
music tells a part of the story without
an actor having to say words that's
incredible sometimes you watch a movie
and you you you are breathless or you
get a chill you're not really sure why a
lot of times it's because of what the
sound is doing I want to encourage
moviegoers to be very analytical just
listen and ask yourself why was that
sound there there's meaning in every
single moment every single you know a
flutter of a butterfly wing and footstep
one of my personal notes about seeing
films and being sold on the on the
effort is when a sound kind of defies
logic and is just so effective you know
when it's placement is is the is doodlee
did the kind of human factor of the
person with the vision like the desk
bell and Barton Fink and just laying
this foot okay you know that that that's
you immediately knew that would sprung
forth from the imagination of that sound
designer but it said it spoke volumes
about the story and the characters sound
guys are not known
to be the creative people of them over
the moviemaking but it's probably more
creative than it is technical you have
to know how to use the BF to know how to
use the equipment right but that's like
the light switch when you walk in the
right exactly right if we were to convey
anything about sound it's not just a
sound guy and we're always referred to
as the sound guy called the
cinematographer the picture guy get
fighters thanks for coming guys we're
all set with some sound advice and you
can go to Oscar calm and fill out your
my pics game ballot and be sure to share
your predictions with your friends